- Me trying to become a
partner at a Big Law firm.
This little maneuver is gonna
cost us 51 years. (laughs)
(upbeat music)
Meme review!
Meme Review is a trademark of PewDiePie.
All rights preserved.
All right, now that
the American government
is boring again...
(tank fires)
(siren blaring)
- Dangers of a possible Russian attack.
Thousands of troops
(thrilling music)
to the border.
- Well, at least from a legal perspective.
Let's get back to a good
old-fashioned legal meme review.
(upbeat music)
Me listening to two pro se
parties argue in open court.
They're just like, they're
puppets or something.
So, pro se litigant
is someone who doesn't have a lawyer.
And I have been in so
different court hearings
where because the judge
is hearing, I don't know,
10 or 20 or 30 different
hearings in that morning,
you have to wait for your turn.
And the pro se litigants
are always just insane.
They just don't know what they're doing.
They're not trained as lawyers.
And so, yeah, the puppets
arguing over nonsense.
And the caption, yeah,
the judge is going to
definitely side with you now.
It's extremely accurate.
(upbeat music)
Law school graduates enjoying their lives
with the Grim Reaper bar
exam knocking on their door.
Oh boy, that brings me back.
That really brings me back.
The thing is with law school,
you go there for three years.
The third year (knuckle pops)
probably is not necessary at all.
And then, you graduate,
and then you have to take the bar exam.
Often, you don't have any money.
The law school loans run out (chuckles)
at the end of your last semester.
And unless you got a cushy big firm job,
you might not have very much money
to actually study for the bar
over the period of three to four months
before you take the bar exam.
So, yeah,
it's a tough time.
And man, the bar exam studying is no joke.
It really does sap up
every ounce (chuckles)
of your will to live.
♪ Hello darkness, my old friend ♪
(upbeat music)
What your coffee preparation
says about the type of law you practice.
Civil litigation, corporate transactions.
So, it took me a second on this one.
First of all, the corporate transactions
getting the the really nice
coffee maker, that makes sense.
Litigation, I think, this
would be funnier if it was just
15 cups of coffee (laughs)
'cause the in-house is not
gonna be doing very much.
No offense, in-house lawyers.
You do good work,
but you do a lot less
than the civil litigators.
But the civil litigators should just have
cups and cups of espresso
'cause we're working
basically all through
the night, all the time.
(upbeat music)
Me trying to become a
partner at a Big Law firm.
This little maneuver is gonna
cost us 51 years. (laughs)
Okay, this is funny probably only to me
and a handful of people in Big Law.
So, all right, how do I explain this?
Big Law tends to be very prestigious.
It tends to be very well-paying.
However, it takes a really long time
and a whole lot of work to
become partner in a Big Law firm.
It varies, some of the smaller big firms,
you can partner in six to 10 years.
In some of the bigger big firms,
you might get in after 12
to 14 years if you're lucky.
And a lot of these huge
firms have up and out
where if you don't make partner
on whatever track they have,
say it's after 10 years, you don't get in.
You will never become a big firm partner.
And some of these big firms let in
eight people into their
partnership a year.
Don't get me started about this.
Anyway, if you screw up one thing
and you're on the partner track,
it's gonna cost you a
lot of time potentially.
And this "Interstellar" clip (laughs)
that it might cost you 51 years.
Dang, it really does feel like that
for some of these firms.
(upbeat music)
Me going into the doc to
turn off tracked changes
and add Oxford commas
without the partner's knowledge. (laughs)
So, Microsoft Word is extremely pervasive
in the big firm world.
And for some reason,
some of those partners out
there don't use Oxford commas.
They're wrong.
(intense music)
They should be ostracized.
But
look, sometimes, they are the boss
and you have to do what they say.
So, it is a very
enterprising young associate
who goes in without tracking the changes
to change things to an Oxford comma,
hoping that the big firm partner
doesn't notice what you have done.
I very much support that decision
because in Oxford comma,
everyone knows it,
the right way of doing things.
(upbeat music)
Live look at class action attorneys
after reaching a settlement. (laughs)
Yeah, so, (laughs)
how do I say this without
offending everyone?
When you have a big class action verdict
or a big settlement,
there's a lot of money
because you're aggregating
lots and lots of small claims.
So, a claim that might be
only $20 if you aggregate it
among a million different class members,
well that's $20 million.
And the people that
really benefit from that
are of course, the class
action plaintiff's attorneys
because they're gonna get a chunk of that,
maybe 30% of that chunk.
And now, I happen to think
class-action lawsuits are very important.
It really does make sure that
the violators of these laws,
whether it's a big
corporation or whatever,
they actually do follow the law
because otherwise,
there would just be a whole bunch of small
infractions that no one
would have an incentive to take to court.
So, class-actions serve
a very important purpose.
That doesn't mean however,
that the class action attorneys
don't make a huge amount of money
when they get a nice fat settlement.
(upbeat music)
There should be law school classes
about how to explain things clearly,
in non-legalese, to clients.
Amen to that.
Well, frankly, I made an
entire YouTube channel
devoted to basically
(laughs) exactly that.
So, if you're having
trouble explaining something
to your client, just
send them to LegalEagle.
They'll tell you (laughs)
the non-legalese way of
thinking about these things.
(upbeat music)
Okay, gonna tell my kids
this was Supreme Court justice
Sonia Sontomayor (laughs)
and Neil Gorsuch. (laughs)
The current controversy there
is reporting that Neil
Gorsuch refuses to wear a mask
around Sonia Sontomayor
despite the fact that she has
some preexisting conditions.
But yeah, you can definitely
feel some not amused vibes
coming from Sophia Vergara here.
That's probably what Sonya
Sontomayor is thinking
even though she would never vocalize it.
(upbeat music)
95% of lawsuits end up
getting settled like...
I'm gonna pay you a confidential (laughs)
sum to (beep) off. (laughs)
Yeah.
Well, yes, on TV,
you see Harvey Specter's
in front of a jury
basically every day of the
week and twice on Sundays.
That is not reality.
It's actually more like 98% of all cases
settled before getting to trial.
And yeah, I bet a good number
of those are in fact confidential.
And a lot of those are for nuisance value.
As this is hinting at in a
not particularly discreet way,
you're just paying off nuisance value
because it's not worth hiring attorney
to defend or whatever,
and it's just cheaper to pay 'em off.
(upbeat music)
Kid thinking of going to law school.
If you're so against it,
then why'd you do it?
Me, you know I'm something
of (beep) idiot myself.
Ah.
I love law school. I really did.
I had a great time. It's not for everyone.
If you don't know what you
wanna do with your life,
do not go to law school.
If you know for a fact
you want to be a lawyer,
law school's probably for you
and you might enjoy it too.
But look, there's a lot of stress,
but I don't think anyone is an idiot
for going to law school,
for the right reasons.
(upbeat music)
Lawyer, this lawsuit
has a 50% success rate.
Client, then do it twice.
Lawyer. (laughs)
It do be like that sometimes.
(upbeat music)
You're getting...
A raise? Oh my god, partnership?
The MSJ we just got served with. (laughs)
All right, MSJ is motion
for summary judgment.
And as we talked about before,
it's really hard to make partner.
It's very easy to get served
with a motion for summary judgment.
That is like a trial on paper.
You're taking all the evidence,
and you're saying,
even if you assume all of
the evidence is true, I win.
And of course, the defense attorneys
are going to have to defend against that.
And it takes a lot of work
to fight a motion for summary judgment.
So, yeah, I feel for Pam here.
And in fact,
I think, the first four Christmases
I ever worked at a big firm,
I was defending against a
motion for summary judgment.
As you become more senior,
you lose less of your vacation time
to having to do the grunt work.
But I have definitely put in my fair share
of responding to motions
for summary judgment.
(upbeat music)
Okay. My law professors
reading my final exam answers.
I think, I have to turn
the sound on this one.
- A stupid son of a-
- Yeah, yeah. All right.
That's exactly what I
thought it was. (laughs)
So, Biden should not have
been saying that to the press.
It was wrong when Trump did it.
It's wrong when Biden did it.
I will say though, now that
I have been a law professor
at Georgetown for a couple of semesters,
there is some truth to this.
Oh, poor law students.
(upbeat music)
All right. Me giving legal advice.
Me living my life. (laughs)
Yeah, look,
I'm Indo Chino on the streets
and I'm Mack Weldon in
the sheets. (laughs)
(upbeat music)
What's something that you
started doing during quarantine,
but want to continue
doing after it's over?
Asking people to mute themselves. (laughs)
Amen, man. Yeah.
Especially opposing council.
(upbeat music)
All right.
The associate who put in
their two weeks notice
when they're asked to do any work.
I missed the part where
that's my problem. (laughs)
Oh boy, man.
So, in the big firm world,
the churn rate is very high.
And once you put in your two weeks notice,
just good luck trying
to get that associate
to do any work whatsoever.
(upbeat music)
A friend just received an email
with a poop emoji from a opposing council.
This is why we went to
law school, I guess.
What?
Oh man.
I have never received a poop
emoji from opposing counsel.
I've never sent a poop
emoji to opposing counsel.
You should have a reasonable amount
of decorum with opposing counsel.
If for no other reason,
then your correspondence
is going to end up in front of the judge
and you wanna put your best foot forward.
That's real dumb. You should not do that.
(upbeat music)
When the judge clowns you
and everyone including your
client (laughs) starts laughing.
Look, the judge is the king
or queen of the kingdom here,
and if they start clowning you,
you just sit there and you take it.
And you say, yes, sir, may I have another?
- Thank you, sir. May I have another?
- Because there's nothing that you can do.
And actually, if you're client is smart,
you laugh at the judge's jokes.
There's no way around it.
- Thank you, sir. May I have another?
(upbeat music)
- Her, I bet he's thinking
about other women.
Him, no interest is good
unless it must vest,
if at all, no later than
21 years after some life
in being at the creation
of the interest. (laughs)
That is the rule against
perpetuities there.
That is the hardest thing to learn
in your property law class. (sighs)
I've done a video on this in the past.
It's not worth going into.
It's about limits to
how long after you die
you can control what
the interest is doing,
'cause otherwise, we'd have
to deal with probate,
decades and decades after someone dies
and you're dealing with their will.
This is funny only to law students.
Just consider yourself lucky
that if you don't understand this joke.
(upbeat music)
Okay.
Walking out of court
after opposing council
said you would never win,
and then you won. (laughs)
That's happened to me a few times.
Opposing council can be
so full of themselves,
and then you just win,
and you just walk out
like you're the king of the world there.
Yeah, it feels good. It feels real good.
And if you do really well in trial,
you might end up in
Morning Brew's newsletter
which is today's sponsor.
I've actually been subscribed
to Morning Brew for forever.
It is one of my absolute
favorite newsletters
and it's awesome that they
wanted to sponsor this channel.
Morning Brew, if you didn't know,
is a free daily newsletter
delivered Monday through Sunday.
It gets you up to speed on business,
finance, tech, and law
in just five minutes,
and provides a fantastic quick summary
of the most important issues
while being witty,
irreverence, and informative.
And did I mention it's completely free?
It tells me how much
my stocks are going up
and how much everyone
else's crypto is going down.
This week, for example,
I learned that no prime
minister of Pakistan
has ever completed a full term in office.
Elon Musk won't be
joining Twitter's board.
And got really interesting
updates about Ukraine.
It's basic exactly the mix of news
that I'm actually interested in.
The stuff that I didn't
know I wanted to know about.
And it's all written in a hilarious style.
Morning Brew is one of the few emails
that I actually look forward
to and open in the morning.
So, LegalEagles, this one
is a complete no-brainer.
Morning Brew is completely free.
It takes less than 15
seconds to subscribe.
So, just click on the link
that's on screen right now
or in the description to
get Morning Brew for free.
And not only will you get a newsletter
that you will actually read,
but you'll actually help
out this channel too.
So, click on the link
that's below to get
Morning Brew right away.
And while you're there,
click on this playlist
with all of my other real law
reviews and legal reactions.
So, click on this playlist
or I'll see you in court.